en estas imágenes manifestantes destri
lanka celebran la noticia un día después
de huir del país y tras una escala en
maldivas el presidente gotabaya
rajapaksa
envió su dimisión por correo al
presidente del parlamento desde singapur
una misiva que será remitida al fiscal
general para una revisión legal y de
autenticidad
antes de ser aceptada formalmente horas
antes los manifestantes que expulsaron
al presidente por su controvertida
gestión de la peor crisis económica de
la historia del país evacuaron los
edificios públicos pero prometieron no
abandonar la lucha
no vamos a quedarnos en este edificio
solo queremos echar al régimen de
rajapaksa y gotabaya rajapaksa ya ha
abandonado el país por lo que no tiene
poderes en blanca así que hemos
recuperado nuestro poder y por eso
abandonamos el edificio antes por la
mañana la policía había hecho retroceder
a manifestantes que intentaban entrar en
el parlamento tras la marcha del
mandatario piden ahora la dimisión del
primer ministro
y créeme sin jaque fue nombrado
presidente interino por el jefe de
estado que unió para el pueblo decir
blanca sigue protestando contra este
gobierno antidemocrático que no tiene en
cuenta nuestras voces por eso estamos
aquí manifestando contra estos
funcionarios que están explotando al
pueblo y créeme zynga prometió dimitir
cuando haya un nuevo gobierno pero los
zelandés es agobiados por meses de
crisis y de escasez exigen un cambio
inmediato y completo de la
administración del país